[Musique]
en suisse une petite révolution à la une
des journaux après une votation un
référendum local
le canton de genève adopte le salaire
minimum 23 francs suisses de l'heure
soit un peu plus de 21 euros pour une
semaine de 42 heures
cela représente 4180 de francs suisses
soit environ 3800 euros
sami du soleil d'alc des clips des clips
et incarne if laisse nos demandes 20
euros de supplément par ce curieux sont
dédommagés un petit peu la réservation
qu'on n'a pas pu faire ce n'était pas
assez clair c'est vrai que ça peut pas
ça vous concerne et et interlocuteur
entre l'électro cuts est interloqué am
c'est
[Musique]
nous avons sur le court numéro sept au
james merci monsieur le journaliste s'il
vous plaît je suis ici sur cette
magnifique terrain
si vous le village le village un petit
peu petit peu comme la météo sur le dos
des hauts et des bas s'il vous plaît
clara burel jeune française de 19 ans
troy 157e mondiale qui bénéficie d'une
invitation à la sortie la néerlandaise
arantxa rus ce en trois manches balle de
match peu après minuit car laurent pour
la première fois les courts annexes sont
équipés de projecteurs le toit sur le
court philippe chatrier et de la lumière
ils auront bientôt l'eau courante
la fermeture des bars qui va donc
s'appliquer jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale mais oui annonce officielle
hier la buvette de l'assemblée est
désormais fermé à partir de 22h pas
d'exception et pour les longues séances
de nuit les députés devront donc
apporter leurs gourdes
moi j'ai des jets des parents qu'on 85
et 88 ans depuis comment dire si moi mes
enfants non interdiction des sacs et 88
ont compris jean laissez-moi terminé
gérard tout le monde fait ça dans les
familles mes enfants ont interdiction de
les embrasser
franchement
là je dois dire que le personnage quoi
je le vois ça paie oui soit sa femme de
johnny ça en fait des dj et dimorphisme
vous voulez sûrement dire eddy mitchell
nom soit des messages par en fait ils
ont 85 et et 82 g 10 85 et 88 c'est
évidemment la furie les français c'est
un scoop je vous le dis aujourd'hui je
me retire officiellement de cette
candidature à la présidentielle
je me retire pour leur faire une fête
tu sais
il
chef
[Musique]
un business hallucinant que vous évoquez
dans votre livre les salons où l'on vend
des barbelés anti migrants notamment la
se passe en europe les barbelés de
modèles concertina qui permettent une
excellente pénétration dans les chairs
l'europe est leader mondial sur ce
marché des barbelés anti migrants il ya
des véritables salon de véritable foire
commerciale les frontières fermées c'est
un vrai business
la monnaie la monnaie une ennemie
aujourd'hui on a un vrai business du
trafic de migrants qui rapporte 35
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires par an ce qui veut dire que
c'est le troisième trafic le plus
rentable au monde derrière le trafic
d'armes et le trafic de drogue avec
cette grosse différence qui le rend si
attractive pour tous les criminels c'est
qu'avec les migrants contrairement à la
drogue ou aux armes quand vous perdez la
marchandise
personne ne vient vous l'a réclamé
[Musique]
toi
ils tentent d'échapper un cacique en
flûte heures sur sa trottinette cette
vidéo très partagés en ce moment a été
tournée en australie
là où ces oiseaux sont particulièrement
agressifs en cette saison leurs petits
viennent de naître
alors ils n'ont aucune pitié pour nous
autres les humains à quelques mètres un
jeune est en train d'être interpellés
par des policiers
il est emmené derrière le fourgon liwan
aimerait savoir pourquoi à chaque watt
tout à coup la tension monte
les policiers sont à cran non ce n'est
pas un super héros mais un secouriste
volant un service ambulancier du nord de
l'angleterre envisage de recourir à
cette combinaison munie de réacteurs
le but secourir les victimes dans des
lieux escarpé comme c'est souvent le cas
ici dans le parc du lake district il ne
s'agit pour le moment que d'un test
ça se passe au pakistan cet homme a
décidé de parcourir le pays à vélo mais
alors sans guide haut et surtout son
frein défi qui évidemment n'est pas
passée inaperçue l'histoire ne dit pas
vraiment de quelle façon il parvient à
s'arrêter mais a priori un pied sur la
lune et pourrait jouer ce test de marche
rapide est utilisé par les médecins pour
évaluer la condition physique en
fonction de l'âge et du sexe
c'est sympa vous voyez du paysage en
actant vous ennuyer pas non séparés
normatif non en train de vie ce que
vivent les vaches en fait sur loire des
lignes de ta me fait pas de pause c'est
toute la journée
c'est pas drôle c'est pas drôle du tout
non
à
georges tu peux nous expliquer la
signification sont des fois le matin
elle sent pas toujours très bon ils sont
parfois on dirait qu'elle est allée
courir deux kilomètres en plein ni macho
vous savez que surcharge pondérale c'est
quand même pas terrible pour la santé
vous connaissez le syndrome du boulanger
ou pas non c'est quand la brioche je
tombe sur la baguette
d'accord on parle un peu mieux oui le
couple ya tout un tas de lois
d'obligations et par exemple la fidélité
sexuelle
messieurs mesdames je voulais pas être
fidèle sexuellement et ben renonçait à
cette obligation bésilate adresse dû
faire un nom salvetat alors ça c'est
hors de question c'est génial quoi a dit
non mais vu la tronche canal pas bernard
alors j'ai été très honoré de vous
recevoir chez moi ça m'a fait très
plaisir j'espère vous avez passé une
bonne soirée
oui maintenant m'arrive aussi